Here's a simple ACME description for a client server system.
At the outermost level is the keyword system indicating that what's being
provided here is a configuration describing this particular architecture.
The system has a name, in this case simple CS, and then contained within it,
are some other statements describing the constituents of that particular system.
In this case, there are two components. One is called client and
one is called server, and there's one connector. Also there are two
attachments for plugging them together. The first component client has one port
out of which requests are sent. The second component server has one port for
receiving a request. The connector, which is called RPC, has two roles.
One of which is called the caller role and one of which is called the callee
role. Then, in a natural fashion to attach these together,
the client's send request port is connected to the connectors caller role.
And similarly the servers receive request port is connected to the connectors
callee role, hence we now plug together.
The client, the server, using the connector in such a way that the ports and
roles are plugged into each other. The system is thus configured in such a way
that the client can send requests using its port through the connectors so
the server receives those requests and can then act upon them.